Speaker 1: All right.
I have a story today from my birth country
of Argentina.
And it is unfortunately just like the worst
of the worst of the stereotypes about Argentineans.
One of the stereotypes about Argentineans
is that they we love to set ourselves apart
from the rest of Latin America and say the
rest of Latin America, you know, these are
Hispanic people, but we're actually European
now.
It's an exaggeration.
It's a stereotype.
It's extraordinarily xenophobic and and racist,
quite frankly.
And the current Argentinean president, Alberto
Fernandez, did exactly this during a meeting
with the Spanish prime minister, Alberto Fernandez
tried to sort of find common ground and to
connect with the Spanish prime minister by
highlighting, hey, we're European like you
guys.
And in so doing, he said, you know, the Mexicans
are just the Indians.
The Brazilians came out of the jungle.
We came on boats from Europe.
We're different.
And it is just the worst of the worst.
Now, many if you've been watching this show
for a while, you know that I am not a Fernandez
guy.
Fernandez is in the line of Cristina Kirchner
and her late husband.
I'm not I'm not a Kershner guy now.
I'm also not a Marcotti guy.
I think that basically in Argentina for decades
now, the choices have been different types
of corruption, different degrees of corruption,
none of which serves the people.
This is controversial among even within my
family, where there are people who are big
Cristina, people who now is the vice president.
They just love Cristina.
And they're going to write to me because I'm
saying this and say I'm wrong about this.
I'm wrong about that.
It's one of the most disgusting regimes that
that I've seen.
But I'm not a marketing guy.
He did some good municipal projects, but it's
not like I'm cheering about center right sort
of trump Trump style marketing.
So in any case, let's get into the video.
I'm going to sort of translate, I guess I
would say, as we go, there are some English
auto generated subtitles, but I will do my
best to kind of let you know what's being
said.
Check this out.
Speaker 2: Markussen they seem to confuse.
A medical a teenager in Kennebunkport, Maine,
so far has a medical that this claim was getting
medical attention with the Continental United.
Property will be determined soon.
Speaker 1: So here he is basically saying,
listen, Argentina, as part of Latin America,
we are pro Latin America, we are Latin American.
But me in particular, I'm also a Europeanist
is the word that not a pianist, a Europeanist,
because I want we consider ourselves part
of Europe.
Let's continue.
Speaker 2: So, yeah, you get in.
Speaker 1: I believe in Europe.
Speaker 2: Forget about it when I was your
boss.
Speaker 1: So now he's quoting Octavio Paz,
but he clearly likes it.
And here's where it gets bad.
Speaker 2: Carlos Ichinose said he the seniors
leaders said you don't what it was.
You know,
Speaker 1: this.
This if.
If.
If you were to do a parody and say what a
stereotype about Argentineans, could we exaggerate
to make Argentineans look as bad as possible,
this would be the script, which would be,
you know, they say the Mexicans came from
Indians, nade natives and Native Americans,
Indians.
However, whatever whatever phrase is, is appropriate
now to refer to the native peoples.
Brazilians came out of the jungle as if you
cannot imagine a more sort of primitive imagery.
But, you know, we Argentineans, we came from
boats that came from Europe, which, of course,
is coded with racial language.
And it's just absolutely nuts.
Let's listen to just the end of it.
Speaker 2: You know, yes.
We want to see the.
Europass here in Denver, I don't really know,
but this
Speaker 1: is just the worst, the worst, the
worst of just sucking up to the idea of of
we listen, we developed we came from Europe
and we developed the country with European
investment.
And it's just so racialized and so xenophobic
and so disgusting.
And in a sense, it's not it it's it's not
even an attack.
It's it's just this offhanded of signal as
to how he views Brazilians and Mexicans in
comparison to Argentina.
And I'm so humiliated by this that this is
so embarrassing because among friends who
understand the stereotypes about Argentina,
sometimes there are jokes made about stuff
like this.
And, you know, if you go to Argentina and
you see there's essentially no what we would
consider black folks in Argentina, there's
a reason why it's disgusting.
It's horrible the history of it.
And, you know, there's a lot of historical
stuff here that it would be great not to associate
with.
And then he just sort of like says what for
many of them is supposed to be the quiet part
completely out loud.
I mean, just just absolutely humiliating and
disgusting.
This guy is horrible.
It's horrible.
And by the way, if you want to if you want
to see corruption on a scale that would make
it would even make Trump blush.
OK, look at what's been going on with vaccination
in Argentina.
Just just look it up and see what you think.